maven is a devops build tool
that is chiefly used for java based
projects
it helps in getting the right jar files
for each project
hi guys welcome to this complete maven
tutorial by simply learn
in this tutorial we will be covering all
the major topics
related to maven we have anuj with us to
take us through
all these critical concepts and several
hands-on demos
throughout the video course so let's
have a look at all the topics
we will be covering today we will begin
with understanding why do we use maven
then we will see the basics of maven
then we shall see the process of
installing maven
on windows ubuntu and mac
we shall understand several basic
concepts of maven
and the maven lifecycle next we shall
have a look at
all the advantages of maven and finally
we will have a look at the top maven
interview questions
these maven interview questions will
help us understand
the structure of the questions that
could be asked in a maven interview
so without any further ado let's get
started but before we begin
make sure you have subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to
click on the bell icon
so you never miss an update from simply
learn
now we will be talking about that how
exactly we can
make use of maven here in performing
various kind of operations whether it's
a build compilation
various kind of stuff there so let's
talk about it why exactly we use
maven here now meven is something which
is a kind of a build tool which is there
for most of the job-based projects here
so this tool also helps us in building
up the source code by downloading some
couple of dependencies
these dependencies are something which
is being configured by the developers
which a developer feels that uh the
project is dependent on and he requires
those dependencies
to be downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a job-based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this
tool will be able to handle that
particular requirement or that project
so it simplifies the uh day-to-day work
of a java developer and helps them in
their projects for
performing daily to daily activities
right now maven also helps us in getting
the
uh specific jar files for each and every
project
so if you are going you can pretty much
make a jar file var file or er file
any kind of a package mechanism you can
follow for your maven day
so to download the dependencies we don't
have to
actually go to the official website of
each and every software
you can easily get it uh the
dependencies of each and every third
party band race
on the mvnrepository.com this is a
website which is present
on which if you visit you will be able
to download the dependencies
which is required by your project or by
your specific
project over here so it totally depends
on how exactly you want to download and
you want to get together
a specific repository over here so
mvnrepository.com is the one if you
visit you will be able to download
and go through all the jar files
dependent jar files as
independences which you require for your
current project
right so now what exactly is a maven all
about so let's see
on that part so maven is a popular open
source build tool
which is uh developed by the apache
group and the primary uh ownership of
this tool is to build
publish and deploy several projects at
once
meven is written in java and it can be
used to build projects written in c
shaft scala ruby etc so apart from
java these are the different programming
languages or the tools which is
supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity
so the tool is uh used for build and
management of any
kind of a jar based project it
simplifies the day-to-day
work of a java developer and helps them
to automate
most of the compilation or build
perspective
tasks on the projects
right now meven is a kind of a
bomb-based project
so uh it also known as an project object
model
and it focuses on of simplification and
standardization of the building process
in the process it take cares of all the
followings here
builds dependencies reports distribution
releases mailing list so all these uh
things are being taken care as in this
particular process here and ultimately
it's an
availability inside the maven that how
the overall build
process needs to be automated and
standardized here
so all these particular mechanisms is
can be followed as such over here so
that we can have a good
standards and the simplifications
implemented as such here
now in this one we are going to talk
about that how we can work on maven
installation on windows and ubuntu
platform here
so first of all we'll do it on the
windows platform here and we'll see that
how the installation really works
so for this one i will be doing the
installation into my local system
now before even going for maven maven is
in kind of a build tool which is
available there primary for performing
any kind of build automation for the
java based projects
now since it's used for java we also
require the jdk installation onto our
system
so for that both of the installations we
will be covering over here
and we'll see that how the installation
really works as such over here
right so before even going for maven uh
we have to install
the jdk onto our windows machine so that
we can proceed with maven because maven
requires
the jdk installation should be there now
there are two ways of jdk installation
either you go for the exe file
or you want to extract the binaries of
jdk to a directory and then
set up the java underscore home path for
that but if you are using in the
executable
that will perform the path
configurations for you also so in that
case you don't have to reconfigure it
again and again
so that's what we are going to see here
so first of all we will try to do the
installation of jdk
so for that we'll go to the website of
jdk and then we have to click on this
one
to access the maven installations part
here
so that's what we are going to do so
let's proceed and let's open the chrome
and try to go through these
two urls so that we can do the
installations one
by one so here i have to just search for
jdk8 download so uh it will show me the
url for oracle.com
so here you will get the jdk for the
different platforms for different
operating systems
now here what you can see here that uh
you have the configurations
in which you have the jdk installation
so we have to
so here i'll go for the windows 64
version because that is something
i will be using to do the installation
so
this is the complete executable link so
here you can download so
we are downloading the sdk a to u 251 so
just search for windows 64 yeah this is
the one so
let me click on this one
let me quickly log into the web page so
once the login is done you will be able
to see
that it's trying to download the exe
file so
that was for the jdk for the java now
for the maven
i am going to go for the maven download
over here
so in this one the maven repo link is
there maven dot
apache.org is the link for this one
now here we have the different options
you can see here that uh the
binaries if like archive is there and
sources
archive is there so depending on the
installation which you want to perform
you should be able to download that file
and it works there
so let's first install the jdk portion
and then we'll go with this one
so we'll click on this one also anyways
because uh it's something we
have to anyways do it so we'll click on
this
so that this maven is also getting
started install or downloading over here
so once both of them are downloaded
we will proceed further with the setup
so let's wait for
another one minute to do this one
so the apache maven is kind of uh
downloaded over here so we
wait for the jdk download also over here
so next five ten seconds only left out
so first jdk will be there and then
maven installation configurations will
be there so
for me when we just have to extract into
a directory and give the envian home
path
into the properties uh into the variable
so that it can pick it up over there
okay so we have to extract the zip file
from a1
give the path and then we will check
with the maven command whether it's
working fine or not
so let's try to install the executive so
we'll open the directory where the
executables are there so first of all
we'll install the jdk
so we'll double click the installer for
jdk it's all for around 200 mb so
the complete jdk will be installed so we
have to just go for
next now when you go with the installer
so usually the
java home parts and all that stuff is
already configured so
you don't really have to change the
passwords or java home
any kind of variable you have to put it
up all those things will be
automatically
cleaned up
it's running the installation
close so then we have to extract the
maven so we have to extract this
directory because
here the maven complete executables and
libraries are there so we just have to
extract it and place into a directory so
that
we can further on use it and access the
path so
once the access is done
yep so this is done there so i can
rename it to
like maven so i can rename it like to
ask me one
and i can cut it down and put it into
the c drive here
now this is the maven home path which is
going to be there
right so all i have to do is that i have
to close this one and
this one and this one and this
so what we have to do is that we have to
really go to the system properties
so that we can extract it so i'm going
to open the
system properties over here
properties now here the advanced system
settings
now in this one we will be setting up
the paths the environment variable will
go
now here if you scroll down you will see
all the different parts which is
available there as such over here
now if we want to see that if the java
is fine or we require for jdk also
so all we have to do is that we have to
open the cmd prompt
window r we are providing so using the
window r i'm opening the
run window where i can say like cmd now
in this cmd i'm going to say like java
hyphen version so java is there so which
means that we don't have any problem
as such now i'll just go here and set up
a new one called
mvn underscore home so here the same
path so you can browse for directory
also but i am using the ambient home
over here in this one
now i have just added that and in the
path variable in the last we have to
actually
add the bin directory also so that uh
whenever we run the
mvn command so that should also be
resolved so mvn
underscore home is not the only variable
which you will be configuring
in fact you will be confirming the path
variable also that you can go ahead and
put up a new directory
entry for the cmd here so cmd
till the cmd directory you will go there
and whatever the executable is there you
should be able to resolve that
so for that again you have to open the
window r cmd prompt java
hyphen version and then you can run mvn
iphone version here when you run the mv
and hyphen version
it will let you know that which
particular java runtime you are using
1.8.0 underscore 251 that's the same one
which we have configured
and it also let us know that where
exactly the executable is there and we
can now proceed further with the
execution
of the maven build so you just have to
check out your source code
or go to the directory where source code
is there and you can run the mvn clean
install so that will
ultimately go for the build process so
this is the way that how we can do the
installation of
maven on the windows platform now since
this is done now we will go ahead with
the second installation where we are
going to
do the installation of maven and jdk on
to the
open to machine so for that we will log
into the particular
cloud lab of simply learn lms so let's
log into the lms here
so now we are going to do uh the
installation of
jdk and maven on the ubuntu virtual
machine here so for that we will log
into the lms so let's
log into that so this is the uh elements
over here here i have already started
the lab here so all i have to do is that
i have to just click on this
link here so it will open the lab into a
new tab it's a gui mode of ubuntu server
so which we will be using to configure
it
so uh here uh first of all i can open
the chrome browser also so let me
open the browser here so that i can
download the maven executables as such
over here
so jdk we can do it using the package
installation so
using the app executable we will be
doing the installation
so i have to just open the terminal here
so once the terminal is opened
you have to log in through the root id
now why we require root id
so that we should be able to do the
package installations and other
configurations
so that requires root access
now once that is done you have to run
the particular
app update command next you have to
install the
installer so the oracle installer we
have to install
now uh once the setup is done so let's
down install the latest
package over here for eco oracle
iphone java 14 hyphen installation
so this will install the jdk 14 over
here
so for that configurations now at the
same time we'll go for
maven download also so here uh
we'll go for download maven so this is
the tar file for executables so i'm
going to copy this
url here and over here
we'll say yes yes
yes so now uh the java should be
configured and could
should be set up over here in this one
so what we really need to do is that we
need to run the java command to see that
if the installation is done properly or
not so uh let's open the terminal again
another terminal so that i can perform
these steps related to maven
so i have got the url so i am going to
the opt directory which is always an
optional directory where we can do the
setup and all those configurations
so i am going to run the wget command
and then the url
which i have downloaded so this should
uh download the tar file over here of
maven now once that is like done so i
have to extract it
so uh tar hyphen xvz f and the entire
file name this is a target zip file so i
have to use
tar hyphen xp zf parameter over here to
extract it
now uh what exactly i have got i have
got the apache maven directory over here
so i am going to rename it
in order to rename it what we need to do
we need to actually go for
uh the particular move command so move
whatever the existing folder you have
and then i'm going to rename it with the
maven directory
now once that is done i'm going to the
maven directory and this is the
path or maven underscore home path which
is available
as such over here in this one so here
all the bin directories executables all
this stuff is there
so now i can use it like mv underscore
home and the same configuration just
like we did in the window so here also
it
the same process we have to follow so
java
hyphen version should be let me know
that which version is deployed so 14.01
version is deployed over here so for
java i do not
don't have to set up the path again here
because i am viewing for the installer
so i don't have to set up the path
right so for maven now what exactly i
have to do i have to
go to the edc profile d
now here i am going to put up a
particular file now here you can see
that we have the jdk
a file here which means that the path
variables and everything is configured
as such over here
so you can see that java underscore home
path all these variables are copied here
so i'm going to also create a same file
similar to this one here but in this
case what i'm going to use it that i'm
going to remove some of the values
so i'm going to have some of the
parameters added so
in order to do it effectively i can do
the echo command
so that i can copy the things from here
and
i can simply put it up into the file
here so i'm going to have the path
variable added up over here now why i'm
putting up the paths
because it's the same configuration
which we did over there also
so opt slash maven
slash pin so all the pin directory
should be added to the
specific path variable so i'm just
trying to create
a file called maven dot ss just like a
jdk dot
sh over here i'm also creating similar
kind of file over here called maven dot
sh
now i'm not going uh in the vi mode or
other editors because i just want to
make you
understand that how i'm copying it the
content i'm taking the jdk.sh as in
reference
and putting up the details over here in
this one and then i'm going to export
mvn underscore home over here which is
related to like
opt slash maven
so this is what we are going to put up
over here and then maven
in the end me when this is the file
which you should be having now why we
are using it
because of the fact that it's being used
or it will be
utilized in such a way that you can
perform the changes or whatever
configurations you want to perform this
will
help you to set up the certain parts
like a path and ambient home so that you
can run these scripts as such over here
so i'm going to give the executable
permissions to this one
and that's it so now what exactly i have
to do is that i have to do the source
here
profile dot d
maven once that is done i will be able
to run the mvn hyphen version over here
and the jdk part is already open so it's
going to refer to that part
so this is the way that how we configure
the mi1 and the jdk
specifically on the ubuntu virtual
machine
so pretty much that's it for this demo
in this demo we primarily talked about
that how we can do the installation of
jdk and maven on windows
and how we can do the similar task on
the maven on the
ubuntu virtual machine also here hello
everyone welcome to this demo
in this demo we are going to talk about
it how exactly we can do the
installation of maven
on the mac operating system so here we
are going to talk about it how we can do
for a specific setup where we can do
for the installation of maven in a mac
operating system
so let's see so there are two ways of
doing the installation here first is
through the
brew executable on the mac now this brew
utility on mac is just like
app or yum utility which is present in
most of the environments or
most of the platforms here but here we
are using this brew to do the
installation of maven on the mac
operating system
and again the next one is just in a
particular mechanism where you should be
able to
have these setup like you can download
the binaries from the apache website
and then you can export the m2 undiscord
home and the path variable so that you
can
start using the maven executable so
we'll talk about these things
and we'll see that how exactly we can go
for this setup so let's login uh
to a particular machine or mac operating
system so where we will be able to do
all this
activity so this is the mac system which
we have here now in this one what we are
going to do is that we are going to open
the terminal
so we are going to open a terminal here
so this is my terminal
so usually in mac you don't require any
other
mechanism so the inbuilt terminal is
more than sufficient for doing this
stuff because
it's similar to a linux based platform
here so i'm going to run the command
here so first of all i'll just double
check that if my brew executable is
working fine
so i'll just run the brew help command
to see that uh if my brew is
working fine as such over here in this
one now i have the
command called brew install so that is a
command which we need to use
now in this one we have to actually give
the specific package which we want to
install so we will say like brew install
maven so it will download uh the
uh specific executables on the
system from the website it will download
the
maven executables so it will take some
time but ultimately it's trying to
download it under the particular tar
file so you can see here that it's
downloading the 3.6.3 dar file over here
so uh i can see that the installation is
done so the 3.6.3 version should be
installed over here
so when i do like maven mvn under hyphen
iphone version over here
so you can see that the 3.6.3 version is
deployed as such
over here now this is something which is
done with the purely command over here
called brew
which really helps us to do any kind of
package installations
not only maven other packages also can
be installed pretty much with the help
of this executable
now in order to see the manual stuff
what we really need to do is that we
need to actually
clean this uh specific installation so
that i should i will be able to show you
the manual installation also over here
so what i'm going to do is that i'm
going to run the command called
brew uninstall maven so that
the maven should be removed from your
system
so we are just trying to remove the
maven from here and uh you can see that
the maven executable
is not working as such over here so
which means that the maven is
uninstalled in this case
but why i have uninstalled here so that
i should be able to
go ahead and download some custom maven
over here in this one
so i have opened the browser here so
i'll go for the maven
executable so we'll go for maven
download so that
we should be able to download a specific
the
executable here so i'm going for this
directory so here uh 3.6.3 version same
is available here
so i'm going to download the bin.gz
which was
uh the file we have so this is also
a kind of a linux platform right so
that's the reason why
uh here the tar file should work
perfectly fine so here i'm going to the
opt directory where we can have all the
optionals
related packages so if it is not there
so i can create a directory called
slash opt so i can
log in with
root so if you don't have the root
access so you can go for the
applications
in the applications you can actually
create a directory called maven
so here i can go for maven
yeah so here we will be
downloading the var file here so the uh
tar.ganji file we are downloading over
here so i'll
give the path here so once the var file
or wkate command i am using to do the
installation but
sometimes the wwg is not available so i
can go for the
brew install wget also if that package
is available on video the installation
will be done
so we'll try to do the installation
using grublucat so that we will be able
to get a tar file generated
or downloaded there are other ways also
you can download it
from the browser also yeah you can go to
the browser and
here you can actually click and download
it and then you can transfer it locally
to this uh specific directory also so
both the possibilities are there
but i'm just trying to download the
double gate command so that it will be
easy for me to do the setup and
to do the download over here so i'm
going to run the same command again
so it will download the tar file so this
is the tar file which is available over
here so
i'm going to extract it over here
so once the extraction is done so i'm
going to rename it like to apache
maven so that i should not have any kind
of versioning or these kind of
parameters over here and the apache data
maven hyphen this star file i'm trying
to remove as such over here
so this is what i have got as an end
result over here
now this is the current directory in
which i have these uh applications and
these setups
going forward over here so if i run the
mvn hyphen f1 version command
so that will not be giving me any kind
of output over here because
still i have extracted the tar file but
that is not the activity is not complete
i have to exactly set up some
environment variables
so that i should be able to run this
ambient command so what i really need to
do over here is that we have to
export certain variables
application slash me1
apache mi1 so this is the home directory
which i'm trying to configure over here
and then next thing is that path
variable so i'm going to have
we are going to carry the path variable
with the folder
so i'm going to have the folder
structure here so
the bin directory we have to provide so
i'm going to
copy here and paste
and then i'm going to carry it with the
bin here so now
my environment variables are established
so
my mvn hyphen iphone version command as
you can see here
is that uh you know it's being picked up
over here but it's saying that the
particular
java runtime is not available so i can
go for java
view install java so that should be
enough there to install a java package
there so
you can see that it says that it's
already installed so and
up to date so that's the reason why it's
not able to
do the installation so i'm going to
reinstall
open jdk
because what happens that when we do the
installation some environment variables
related to java should be
formatted or should be extracted over
here right so as you can see that uh
here it's saying that if you want to
really use the
executable of java you have to
concatenate the path like this
so let's run that and uh then we can see
that
the particular executable of java
will also be find out over here so java
hyphen version
showing that yes it's available there
and now my command
should be able to show me that yes it's
working fine the gdk was already
installed but the problem with that is
that since
it's installed into a particular
location so you have to actually
override your path value so that you
should be able to see in that directory
and find out the java executable
so that i have got by doing the
installation i got the command over
there
in the output saying that this is the
installation which is done and now you
just have to extract or you have to just
you know put that bar directory into the
specified
uh path variable and that's how you got
the maven
and java both command lines working over
here so this is how you will be doing
the maven installations all together
how the overall installation of maven
and the jdk
really works on mac operating system
now what exactly is a maven repository
all about
so maven repository is uh something
which
is a kind of a directory or it's kind of
a
location where we have all the jar files
packaged
all together in a single location so
depending on the software which you want
to download
the dependent java files can be
downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the palm files
relevant to each project here
this metadata is what allows maven to
download the dependencies
now there are three type of repositories
from where we can download the
dependencies
the first one is the local repository
second one is the remote repository and
the third one is the central repository
so these are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for a specific maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go
with that right
now the local repository will be primary
present
onto your pc that's the way that how
it's present there
and the uh particular remote repository
something which you can store on any
remote
machine or remote server and the central
repository is something which you can
have it onto the
internet so usually the central
repositories is something in which
we can actually host our different kind
of dependencies
and the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine
remote machine is the location where you
can actually store all your
particular dependencies from where you
can download these dependencies whenever
you require it
so this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from the remote repository
it's first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local
it will be first downloaded from the
remote repository and then it will be
utilized or
will be referenced onto the local
machine there
and central repository is refers to the
maven community repository there
where you will be able to see each and
every dependency present
on that repository so maven downloads
the repositories from here in the local
repository whenever they're needed or
whenever required
all these dependencies are cached
locally from where it will be referenced
in the next or you know whenever we want
to refer that
we will be able to do that particular
reference easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories or movement
repositories really helps us
for performing various kind of
automations as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
maven here so
some of the couple of basic concepts
which is present in maven is like
for the first time we have the project
object model so
project bomb reference to the xml file
which
has all the information regarding the
project how this
particular project should be built up
how the different build process should
be automated there
it also has a description of the project
details regarding the versioning version
information
is also stored as such in this xml file
in this
particular form reference file as such
over here the xml file is which is there
in the project
home directory so maven is something
which search for the pawn file in the
current directory
if it's able to find that particular
palm file so it will execute or it will
proceed with the
build step otherwise they it will hold
there itself so this pawn file is very
important because it will act as
a kind of a built script and primary the
maven tool will be able to process
each and everything which is configured
as such in this specific xml file there
and according to that only it will
function or it will proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
java files so the java libraries
which we need in our into our particular
project so while
uh working on the project we may be
having the dependency on couple of
dependencies
so these dependencies we have to
actually download or we have to actually
refer
and once these a particular information
or these details are referred
so what will happen that uh we need to
download these
specific dependencies from the
particular maven repositories
so if their dependencies are not present
in your local repository then maven
will try to download it from the central
repository and cache it into your local
repository
but first of all it will look on into
the local repository and if it is not
present in local then
it will go to the remote or the central
repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goals there so build lifecycles
consists of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here
now each goal is responsible for
performing a specific task
when a phase is uh running all the goals
related to that phase
and its plugins are also used to
following the compilation
preparing the artifacts downloading the
dependencies all different things being
done by the
plugins here then we have the build
profile so build profiles refers to a
set of configuration values
now generally we have the generic build
process for all the environments all the
particular code base there
but sometimes we do have some kind of a
differences there so that is where we
can go for the profiles because a
specific profile can have
its own configuration and whatever it's
required for the build process
we can have different different
configurations stored inside the
maven build script here then with
different
build profiles are added to the palm
files and which
enables the different uh build as such
here so depending on these profiles we
can actually decide
that how we need to proceed with the
build process and how the different kind
of
build order missions needs to be
performed here then a build profile
helps in customizing the
build for the different environments so
that also we can perform
as such while performing or while
working on the different components and
the different management here
so a build profile is something which
you can configure
you can utilize and depending on that
build profile we will be deciding
whether to proceed further
or how to decide on that particular
factor so these are something which we
need to take care
or we need to work according to which we
can decide that how
the specific configurations and specific
automation
needs to be performed here
now usually when we go for the um even
there so we have to use some couple of
maven plugins
now the goal of using these uh specific
plugins is to
automate some of the basic stuff like
compilation creating the var file
creating the java file
so when we are using the plugins we
don't have to configure the steps or
write the steps
that how these uh specific plugins
should be installed
or should be referenced it's ultimately
the internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how
a specific goals needs to be achieved
here
so maven has its own standard plugins
that can be utilized
so if you know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and uh
you can pretty much
have some specific goals executed with
the help of these
build now next thing is the maven
architecture so
uh in maven what happens that uh let's
talk about the basic architecture of
maven here so
the maven executable when it's deployed
so it usually uh
reads the palm.xml file which is the
build script here
now once the specific found xml file is
being read out
so it will uh process the components it
will uh
you know download or it will process the
dependencies plugins
life cycles phases and goals and even
the build profiles
and if any kind of interaction is
required so it will
try to connect to the central repository
or remote repository
and according to that it will provide
the information and provide the details
as such so minimum repository is
something which is very important
because it's ultimately trying to
connect to the maven repository
and try to achieve the various kind of
automation here
so it's very important because
ultimately it's trying to help us to go
for the
complete end-to-end build automation
when we will go for
a specific bomb based build automation
so a movement executable read the
pom.xml file then download the
dependencies defined into the power xml
file
and that dependencies are cached locally
from the remote or the central
repository
now then uh create and generate a remote
uh report according to the requirement
and execute the life cycles phases goals
plugins etc
so it will process the pawn rectangle
file then and whatever the plugins
and goals or the life cycles which is
configured there step by step each of
them will be executed into a sequence
here
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that
uh the maven build lifecycle is
something which is
a kind of a collection of different
steps there and this is something which
is followed
to perform a build automation for a
specific project
so they are pretty much three steps
which is being done so first one is the
default
so it handles the project deployment
there second
handles the project cleaning which is a
clean there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the beaver level
which you can utilize to perform a
various kind of particular steps
execution for your
project right so the build cycle has
the different build phases or stages
there because when we are performing a
build a variety of things needs to be
performed over here
so the first one is the compile then
test compile is there so compilation is
there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle
then we have the integration test to run
the integration test cases
then we have the verify then install
goal is there and the last one is the
deploy which is there to deploy
the artifacts to the artifact tree so
all these things are the different
phases and the
stages which is being followed as per a
specific build here
so during these builds these are the
different phases and these stages which
we
normally follow for performing the build
automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific
maven here so that is something which we
need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to
take certain benefits out of the
implementation of maven here
so for that what happens that uh we have
to see that the various kind of uh
benefits
the first one is that apache mi1 helps
manage
all the processes there such as building
documentation
releasing and distribution in project
management here
so the tool simplifies the process of
project building
it increases the performance of the
project and the building process
all together and the task of downloading
jar files and other dependencies
is also done automatically we don't have
to indulge in any kind of download part
as such manually over here right and
maven provides easy access to all the
required information so may 1 makes it
easy for
a specific developer to build a project
in the different environments so we
don't have to worry about the
environment
we don't have to worry about the
infrastructure nothing is required
everything is available there inside
this package and you know depending on
the
particular you can write the source code
on one machine and you can pretty much
do the build on another machine and this
is the reason how the build automation
really happens on the first place
because the developer is writing
the source code in one location and the
same code is deployed onto the
particular or built onto this jenkins or
any kind of build tool there
right in maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must
write the particular dependencies in the
form file so if you feel that you want
to download some particular dependencies
so all you have to do is that
you have to put that dependency into the
specific
palm.xml file there and depending on
that the execution will be really
performed and executed as a chair
right so let's talk about the demo now
so let's see that how exactly we can go
for this demo and we can
perform the various kind of automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like
mvn
so maven will be available as in three
point six point three here
now i'm going to run a particular
command called uh mvn archetype
generate here let me create a directory
here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
arc type
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will
uh download some of the binaries there
because uh
ultimately what we are trying to do is
that we are trying to generate a new
project
like a maven project so couple of uh
particular
plugins will be downloaded by the maven
executable so that it can
achieve that particular execution so we
just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here
so what exactly we want to configure so
if you want to configure you can provide
that details otherwise
you can perform or whatever the setup
you want to perform
now here it's asking for the version so
which kind of version we want to follow
so i'm going to follow like five here
so i'll press five then a group id which
is there so
it's basically a kind of a group
mechanism so i can say like com
dot simply learn so that's the value
which i'm providing here
artifate id i can make it like a sample
project or something like that uh i can
do
so that will be the artifact uh id which
is there so
version i'm keeping the same only so and
uh yeah so package same here
so i just want to create so i'll just
provide the value called yes
and enter so with this what will happen
that a sample project will be created
here
right so whatever the artifact id you
provided so according to that
the project is created in this directory
so you have to go into this directory
and see that what exactly the files are
created there
so you have the power.xml file now this
form.xml file when i open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version or group id
you want to follow so this is a group id
this is the artifact id so this is jar
file by default you can change it
according to your requirement then this
is the
version and if you feel that you want to
do the changes to the name
that also you can perform here so by
default the junit dependency is added
but
if you want to keep on adding your own
custom dependencies
you will be able to do that now in this
case
if you run like mvn clean install
so it will be considered as in
particular maven project
a palm xml file is already there present
in the local directory
so according to that the execution of
the steps will be performed
and according to that you will be able
to get some desired values here
so ultimately in the target directory
you will be able to see that some couple
of jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the target directory this jar file or
this artifact
is generated here so this is a way that
how we can actually go for a generic one
like a new uh particular project
and later on you can depending on your
uh understanding you can keep on adding
or you can keep on modifying
the dependencies and that's how you can
get the final
result there so that's it for this demo
uh in which we have find out that how
exactly
we can go for a particular project
preparation with the help of mvn
executable
welcome everyone to this topic in which
we are going to talk about that what
exactly is the different maven
interview questions here now in this one
we are going to talk about what are the
different
questions some couple of questions we
are going to go through and
we'll try to understand that what
exactly the answers are
now let's talk about the first question
over here so what exactly is in maven
here
so maven is nothing but a kind of a
popular open tool uh open source build
tool which is
available there now before maven there
were a couple of
build tools which was present like and
and you know a lot of other
legacy tools was present there but after
that
maven is something which was uh released
as an open source tool
and it really helps the organization to
uh automate some couple of build
processes and
you know have some particular mechanisms
like build publish and deploy
of different different projects at once
itself
so it's a very powerful tool which can
really help us to do the build
automations we can integrate them with
the other tools like jenkins and
you know we can automate them we can
schedule the builds
so a lot of various advantages we can
get with the help of this tool here
it's primarily written in java and uh it
can be used to build up various other
kind of projects also like c
sharp scalar ruby etc so all these other
typical tools can also be built up with
the help of this tool
so this tool is primarily uh used to do
the
uh particular development and management
of the artifacts in the java based
projects
so uh for most of the java based
projects nowadays this is the default
tool
and it's already integrated with the
eclipse also so when you go for a new
wavelength project
automatically uh it will be created for
a java project you can use it for other
languages also but yes
default choice of java of of the
java programming language is maven build
tool only
now let's talk about next question so
what does the maven help with
so may when apache maven helps to manage
all the processes
such as build process documentation
release process
distribution deployment preparing the
artifact so all these
tasks is being primarily taken care by
the apache maven
so this tool simplifies the process of
project building
it also increases the performance of the
project and the overall building process
so all these things are something which
is being taken care
by the specific maven tool here so it
also
uses the particular uh you know it
downloads the jar files of the different
dependencies
for example if your source code is
dependent on
some of the apache web service jar files
or some of the other third-party jar
files
in that case you don't have to download
those jar files and keep in some
repository or keep it in some lib
directory you just have to mention that
dependency in the maven and that jar
file will be downloaded
during the build process and will be
cached locally so that's the biggest
advantage which we get with maven that
you don't have to take care of all these
dependencies
anywhere into your source code system so
maven provides easy access to all the
required information
it uh helps the developer to build the
projects and uh without you know even
worrying about the dependencies
processes or different environments or
different because it's in a kind of
a tool which can be used in any platform
linux or windows so they don't have to
do any kind of conversions
so all they have to do is that they have
to just add new dependencies
and that should be updated into the pom
file and depending on that
dependencies the source code will be
built up and they don't have to refer
any kind of third party jar files so
they don't have to play with the class
bars during the build process so no
customizations
is actually required with this one now
the next question is that
what are the different elements that may
one take cares of
so there are different kind of elements
which is being taken care by maven so
these particular parameters are elements
are bills
dependencies reports distribution
releases and mailing list so these are
the typical different different uh
elements which is being taken care by
the maven during the build process and
during the preparation of the builds
here
so all these things you can uh they can
explore they can extract on that part
and they can fully understand that how
they can
work on all these different different
processes now next question is that what
is the difference
primary difference between the and and
maven first of all both of them are
primarily used for the java based
project so and is the older version and
maven is something which was launched
after the
ad here so and has no formal conventions
like
so which can be uh you know coded into
the build.xml file there but yes
the maven has convention so information
is not required as such in the palm.xml
file there
so ant is procedural whereas v1 is
declarative over here
so and does not have any kind of life
cycle so it depends on you that how you
program the and there
but maven is having a lot of life cycles
there which we can configure we can
utilize
so the uh and related scripts are not
reusable because you cannot reuse it
and you have to do some kind of
customizations in order to work on that
but yes
maven is not having much of the project
related any kind of dependencies
they can be easily reusable there
because there is nothing about
the palm.xml file it's just the artifact
name and the dependencies which is uh
something we can override or we can
change and then the same palm.xml file
we can reuse as such for the new project
also
so that is where the reusability comes
into the picture
now and is a very specific build tool so
we don't have to
there is no plugins as such which is
available there you just have to code
everything that what build process you
want to prepare
whereas in case of maven we have the
concept of plugins which can really help
us to understand that how we can
make or use of these plugins so that we
can have the reusability
implemented so these are some of the
differences which is available there
between the and
and maven here now next thing is that
what exactly isn't palm file all about
so palm file is nothing but it's kind of
a
xml file which is available there and
it's have having all the information
regarding the project
and the configuration details so it
primarily used over here that how the
configuration needs to be done
and how the setup should be performed as
such here
so palm technical file is the build
script which we prepare
uh you can prepare it uh using a
particular component
or you can have a particular mechanisms
or if you feel that you want to have
some kind of setup so all these things
typically can be implemented can be
done with the help of build tools so
build tools can be really helpful for us
to do the automations and it can really
help us to understand that how
some build processes we can automate
with simply with the help of palm.xml
file here
so the developers usually put up uh
everything inside these uh dependencies
in the palm.xml file here
so this is the file which is uh usually
present in the home directory it's in
the current directory
so that once the build is triggered it
will be picked up from that directory
and according to the steps according to
the content of the palm.xml file
the build will be processed or will be
created here
now what i'll include into the palm file
here so
the different components which is
included into the palm dot xml file here
is the dependencies
uh developers and contributors plugins
plugin configuration and resources so
these are the typical components which
is a part of a permanent xml file
which can be uh same form lot of
projects you can do some customization
and then
the same pom file can be reused for the
other projects also
now what are the minimum requirement of
the elements which is there for a palm
for
uh powered xml file so without which the
pound xml file will not be validated and
will will be getting a kind of
validation errors so the minimum
required elements are project root
model version so it should be 4.0.0 the
group id of the project the artifact id
of the project and the version of the
artifact
these are the minimum things which we
want to define so that we can understand
that
what kind of artifact we are trying to
prepare or we are trying to create here
so these are the minimum required
elements which is required in the
palm.xml file without which the
validation of the palm file will fail
and the build will also fail here
now what exactly is the mint uh with the
term called build tool
so build tool is an essential tool is a
kind of a process for building or
compiling the
source code here so it's needed or it's
required for the below
for generated processes if you want to
generate the source code if you want to
compile the source code you want to
generate the source code
you want to generate some documentation
from the source code
you want to compile the source code or
you want to package the source code
whether it's a jar file it's a war file
or it's a er file
so whatever the packaging mode you want
to select you will be able to do it with
the help of
the particular build tool here and if
you feel that you want to
upload these particular artifacts to the
artifact tree
whether it's on remote machine or
locally there so that also you can do it
with the help of
this particular build tools here so
build tools can be
helpful in doing a lot of activities for
the developers
now one of the different steps which is
involved to install maven on windows
now all you have to do is that you have
to just first of all download the
uh tar file from the maven apache maven
repository there once that is done so
what happens that you have to set up
some couple of environment variables
now if you download the java jdk using
the exe file in that case the java
undisco home will be configured
automatically
but if it is not available and you are
not able to run the java command line
in that case you have to set up the java
underscore home
and then similarly for maven you have to
go for the maven underscore home
that particular variable you have to
configure now once that is done
all you have to do is that you have to
edit the path variable
so the bin directory of the maven
extracted a folder you have to put it up
into the path variable
and once that is done what will happen
that you will be able to
check the latest version the version of
the maven over there if it is like some
old version
again you have to extract the latest
version and do the steps all together
again
so these are some of the ways that in
which you can actually go for the
installation or the
configurations of maven on the windows
platform
now what are the different steps which
is involved for the installation of
maven and ubuntu
so ubuntu it's fine you just download
the package of java jdk there
once the jdk is installed over there
what you can do you can simply go ahead
and say that yes
i want to search for a particular maven
uh package which is available there
so once the jdk is installed all you
have to do is that you have to configure
the java underscore home
m3 underscore home main and disco home
and the path variable
once all the path variables are
something which is configured
then you will be able to check the
latest version like whether it's a
the version is correct or we are getting
the standard version
over here or not over here so that's the
main mechanism that
how we will be able to you know
configure the maven on ubuntu here now
what exactly is the command to install
to char
into the locals repository now sometimes
what happens that
we are not able to fetch like uh some
dependencies not present on the
uh particular central repository minimum
repository or your artifactory
repository
in that case you have some third-party
jar which we want to install locally
onto your repository so in that case we
can go for the
uh but we can download the jar file
there and then we can run the command
called
mvn install install hyphen file
and then we are giving the path like
hyphen d file where the path of the file
should be provided
now once that is done so what will
happen that in the local dot m2
directory
this specific artifact will be
downloaded and will be installed here
so this is a mechanism where you will be
able to configure or you will be able to
set up
the artifacts locally the java file
locally here in the local repository
so next question is that how do you know
that the version of the maven being used
here
so the inversion of the maven is pretty
easy to calculate
so all you have to do is that you have
to just go for mvn
and space hyphen iphone version the
moment you do that it will let you know
that what jdk or what java version you
are using
and it will also show you that what
particular maven version
you're going to use here so all that
details you will be able to get with
that particular command here
now what exactly is the clean default
and frightened variable here so these
are the build cycles which is available
there in within maven
so these are the built-in build cycles
so for clean
what happens that this life cycle will
help you to
perform the project cleaning so usually
during the build there are some files
which is created into the target
directory
so the clean life cycle is essentially
helping us to clean up
all that directory all that particular
target directory and when we talk about
the
specific default so default lifecycle
handles the projector deployment
that is the default uh lifecycle and
site is something which is uh you know
helpful for creating the site
documentation
you know it's kind of a life cycle which
is available there so clean
default and site are the different life
cycles which can perform different
different
kind of uh attributes or different tasks
here next question
what exactly is a maven repository so
maven repository
refers to the directories of the package
jar
files that contain metadata now the
metadata refers to the palm
files relevant to each project so here
you can able to get your artifacts
uh stored there you can download these
artifacts also during the maven build
if you put up that dependency you will
there are different kind of repositories
which is available there
one is the local repository one is a
remote repository and one is the central
repository
so these are the different typical type
of repositories which we have
where we can store the artifacts also
and from where we can download the
artifacts also whenever
required now the first one is the local
repository so local repository refers to
the machine
of the developers itself where all the
project related files are stored there
now whenever we work on the uh
particular maven so there is an in the
home directory dot
m2 folder is created now usually
whatever the artifacts downloaded from
artifactory or from the
maven repository it gets cached locally
there
and once it is downloaded next time it
will not download the same artifacts or
the same
dependency altogether again so this
local
repository is something which is
available locally on the
developers machine only so it contains
all the dependent jars
which a particular developer is
downloading during the maven build
now remote repositories refers to the
repository which is present on the
server
and uh with from where we will be
downloading the uh particular
dependencies
so the when when we are running the
movement build on a fresh machine
so usually over there the local
repository does not exist
so in that case what happens that the
dot m2 directory is empty
but the moment you run the build what
will happen that the artifacts or the
dependencies
will be downloaded from the remote
repository and uh once it is done
once it's uh downloaded it will be added
or it will be downloaded cached
locally there and it will be uh helpful
in the future run so that will be
considered as a local repository because
all the artifacts
all the dependencies are downloaded
there and central repository is
something which is known as the maven
community
where all the artifacts is available
there so usually we cache
or we mirror these central repositories
as our particular
remote repositories because it could be
a possibility that these remote
repositories are something
which we are hosting into our
organization and central repository is
something which is available centrally
for everyone
to use it so these are something
you know some kind of repositories where
each and every artifacts will be stored
and anyone will be able to have the
access to these
particular artifacts here so these
artifacts are
every artifacts every open source uh
artifacts is something which is
available
over there to these central repository
now how does the
maven architecture really work here so
the mimon architecture really works in
the three steps
the very first step is that it reads the
palm.xml file here that's the very first
step
second it downloads the dependencies uh
defined in the power xml file into the
local repository
from the central or the remote
repository here once that is done so it
will
uh you know create or generate the
reports according to the
life cycles which you have configured
whether it's a clean
install site deploy
package or whatever the life cycle you
want to trigger you will be
triggering that particular life cycle
and corresponding to that the build or a
specific task will be performed
so these are the three steps in which
the overall build
or any kind of uh execution of palm.xml
file
really happens here now what exactly is
the maven build lifecycle
so maven lifecycle isn't nothing but
collection of steps here
that needs to be uh followed for doing a
proper
uh build of a project here so there are
primary three built-in
cycles which is available there default
which handles the project deployment
clean which handles the project uh
cleaning there and site which handles
the creation of the project sites
documentation
so these are the three primary built-in
build cycles
life cycles which is available as such
now so build life cycle has you know
different kind of phases or the stages
here
because in the previous uh particular
slide we were talking about what
what are the different uh particular
build life cycles which is available
there
but these are the different phases like
what are the different step-by-step
executions like for the deep down which
is available there inside a specific
maven build life cycle
so here you can see that it's compiling
then the test compile
test execution is there then package
integration test to verify
install and the lastly deploy here so
these are the different
build phases which is available as such
over here
so what exactly is the command to use to
do a particular maven site
so mvn site is something which is used
to create a maven site here
now usually whatever the artifacts is
prepared that will be prepared in the
target directory
so here also you will be able to see a
site directory which is available there
in the target directory
which you can refer for the site
documentations what is the different
conventions used while
naming a project in maven so usually
it involves three components so the full
name of a project in maven includes
first of all the group id
uh for example count at apache
com.example so these are some of the
particular way that where you can
provide the group id artifact id can be
exact project
name like maven project or uh whatever
the project you are creating so sample
project example project
so these kind of things will be there in
the artifact id
and lastly is the version like which
version of your artifact you want to
prepare like 1.0.0
hyphen snapshot 2.0.0 so like this
information you are providing that what
particular version you are trying to
configure here
now let's move on to the intermediate
level where we will be having a little
bit more complex questions
related to the maven here now what
exactly is a maven artifact
now usually what happens that when we do
a build process
as an end of result of the build process
we will get some artifacts
for example when we build a.net project
so there we will be able to have a exe
or dll files as an artifacts
similarly in case of maven when we do a
build process
there we get the different kind of
artifacts like depending on the
packaging mode like
jar file var files or the er files here
so these are something which is you know
getting generated during the build
process during the main process
and you can store them into your local
repository or you want to push them to
the
remote repository it's something that
totally depends on you
so maven is a tool which can help you to
create all the artifacts whether it's a
jar file whether it's a var files or
whether it's a
er file here and every artifact is
having three attributes the first one is
the group
id the artifact id and a particular
version and that's how you will be able
to identify a full-fledged artifact
as such in maven so maven is not about
only the name of the jar file
it's actually referring to the
attributes like crop id the artifact id
and the version of the artifact here now
what are the different phases of the
clean life cycle here
so clean is something which is being
used to clean the target directory so
that a fresh build can be triggered
there
so there are three steps pretty clean
clean and post clean here
so if you wish that you want to override
the particular life cycle configurations
and you want to run some particular
steps before the clean activity
so you can do it into the pre-clean and
if you want to do it like some steps
after clean then post clean can be
utilized now what are the different
phases of the
a site life cycle so pre site site
post site and site deploy so these are
the different phases which is available
there in the
site life cycle what is exactly we meant
by the maven plugin
now this is the huge difference between
the ant and maven here because
in and we were not having this that much
support of the plugins and that's the
reason why we had to deal with
all the build configurations so we have
to simply put
the overall build process that how the
build should be triggered but that is
not something which is there in case of
maven
in maven we have a lot of flexibility
because we can actually put up
what exactly build configurations we
want to put here we can
put some features like important
features over here in maven
and uh these plugins we can utilize for
example i want to perform a compilation
now i don't really want to do any kind
of configurations in this one so
what i can do is that i can simply use
the compilation plugin in maven
and that can really help me because i
don't have to
unnecessarily write or rewrite the
configuration that how the compilation
should be done
it's something which is pre-configured
or pre-written in this plugins
that i can simply import the plug-in and
i can do the build process or the
compilation process
in a pretty standard mode so i don't
really have to
do any kind of workarounds with that and
simply with a small
automations i will be able to reach that
how these maven plugins can be
integrated into my palmer xml file
and i can desire or i can have some
particular procedures
and some steps executed there so that's
the biggest benefit
which we really get with the help of
maven plugins now
why exactly the maven plugins are
utilized so to create a jar files
to create the war files to compile the
code files
to perform the unit testing to create
the project documentation
and to create the project reports so
there are a variety of things
in which we can actually use these maven
plugins
through the integrations within the
palm.xml file there so it's all about
the plugins
you just import the plugin and that
desired activity will be performed there
now what are the different type of
plugins which is there so
you can have either build projects uh
for performing the build activities you
can have some build plugins
for reporting plugins also there which
can be only generated or utilized
to generate the reports to process the
reports and do
any kind of formatting or any kind of
processing on the reports here so that
is where the reporting plugins
are utilized now what is exactly the
difference between the convention
and the configuration in maven so
convention is in particular process when
the developers
are not required to create the build
processes so configuration is when you
know the developers are supposed to
create the build
processes so the users do not have to
rectify the configuration in detail
and once the project is created it will
automatically create
a structure so they must specify
every in case of configuration you have
to provide each and every details
so that's how the uh configurations
really happens because
um you have to put every detail into the
power xml file
and that's how the particular
configurations really work
as such so this is the huge difference
between the conventions and the
configurations here
now so why exactly said that maven uses
conventions
over the configurations maven pretty
much does not puts any efforts like on
the
particular developers that they have to
put each and every configuration so
there are some ready-made
uh plugins which is available there and
pretty much we are making use of that so
that in such a case we don't have to
worry about the
executions and we will be able to pretty
much work on that
so conventions like maven uses the
conventions incident of the
configurations
so the developers just you know they
don't just have to create the human
project
the rest of the particular structure
will be taken clear automatically
so they are not uh you know expecting
that the developers should be doing the
configuration work
and everything should be taken care in
such a way that you just have to start
the things
and the rest of the things should be
taken care by the maven itself so maven
will be
uh responsible because they do the
plugins it will be responsible to set up
the default architecture
the default folder structures and all
you have to do is that you have to just
place the source code in the desired
folder structure here so that's
something which you need to do
as on particular developers so what
exactly is the maven
order of inheritance here so the order
of inheritance is the settings
cli parameters parent pom and the
project form which means that
if you have some configuration and
settings that will be the highest value
then the cli parameters are there then
the parent palm is there
and then the project palm so this is the
way that how the
particular parameters or the
configurations will be picked up by the
may one so
that's the order so what does the build
life cycles and the phases
imply in the basic concept of maven so
build life cycles
consist of a sequence of build phases
and each build phase consists of a
sequence of goals
when a phase is run uh all the goals
related to that phase
and its plugins are also compiled so
you will be able to have a lot of
particular goals which is
residing inside of phase there and
similarly life cycle is nothing but a
kind of a sequence of the different
phase
so life cycle comes in the top then it
comes on the phases and then it comes on
the goals here
now what is the terminology called goal
in case of maven the term a terminology
goal refers to the specific task
that makes it possible for the the
project to be built and organized so
it's something which we can run
so it's an actual implementation which
is going on there for example in the
build process in the
build phase i have a different goals
like clean
install package deploy these are the
different typical
goals which is available there which i
can execute into the main one here so
these are the different
goals like uh which we can execute and
which we can run during a maven build
next question is what is exactly meant
by the term dependencies
and the repositories in maven here so
dependencies refer to the java libraries
which we
usually put up into the bound.xml file
there now what happens that sometimes
our source code is requiring some java
files like a
secondary jar files for performing the
build process so
instead of downloading it and storing it
into the class path for during the build
process
we just have to specify the dependency
of that
artifact what dependency we need to put
and once that dependency is put up there
we will be able to
have that jar file downloaded and cached
into the local repository during the
maven build project
now if the dependencies are not present
in your local repository
then maven will try to download it from
the central repository and again if it
is not a
you know it's something which is
available which is downloaded from the
central repository then it will be
cached locally into the
local repository so that's the cycle
which is being implemented
and utilized during this process now
what exactly
is in snapshot in maven so snapshot
refers to the version
already available in the movement report
repository it signifies the latest
development copy
that's what we do with the case of
snapshot here
so meven checks for a new version of
snapshot in the remote repository for
every new build
so during the build process like you
know a new snapshot version is being
downloaded
and the snapshot is updated by the data
service team which
uh with updated source code every time
to the repository for each maven build
so snap shot is something which we will
be using like very frequently we will be
updating to that
and frequently we will be updating the
version to that and we will try to
explore and we will try to do the
modifications
now what are the different type of
projects available in maven so there are
thousands of java projects which
you know uh can be utilized or we can be
uh implemented by my one here
so this helps the as the user that
they as they no longer have to remember
every configurations
to set a particular project for example
spring boot
spring mvc spring boot etc these are the
different projects which is
already available in maven so most of
the we have already discussed that
for the job-based projects maven is
something which is you know considered
as by default
so a lot of organizations are actually
using it for you know storing or
utilizing it for the uh particular maven
project now what exactly is the
maven uh archetype over here so maven
octave refers to a maven plugin that is
uh
entitled to create a for project
structure as per its template
these archetypes are just project
templates that are generated by maven
when any new project is created there so
this is something which we are using so
that we will be able to
create a fresh new projects right so
let's go on to the advanced level of
this maven questions
now what exactly is the command to
create a new project
based on an archive type so mvn
archetype
generate is used to create a new java uh
project based on the archetype
now this will take up some parameters
from
as an end user from you and depending on
that parameters
it will create the palm.xml file it will
create the source directories
uh inside that main java test all these
different couple of directories
directory structures will be
automatically created now why we require
this command
so that if you are going to create a
project from scratch from the
from the day one this command will help
you to have all the folder structures
created
and then further on you can put up your
source code and those files
as such in this folder structure so
that's how
is the mechanism that we will be able to
see that how the setup can be performed
really over here now what does maven
clean implies now movement clean is a
plug-in
that suggests that it's going to clean
the files and directories there
so whenever we do a build process
usually in the target directory we have
some class files
some jar files or whatever the generated
source code which is available
that will be present in the target
directory so the maven clean is
something which is
available which is going to clean all
these directories
and why we are doing this directly
structure cleanup
so that we will be able to do a fresh uh
build process
and there should not be any kind of
issues
as such over here so that's the main
reason why we are looking forward for
this
uh particular mechanism or for this uh
particular changes as such here
now so what exactly isn't build profile
all about so build profiles refers to
the set of configurations
uh where we can have like typically two
different kind of build processes there
so if you feel that the same form.xml
file you can use you want to run for
different different
uh particular configurations so that you
will be able to do pretty much
with the help of this component so build
profile is used to do a customization
processes so that you will be able to
have the process
and you will be able to perform the
configurations and the setups all
together there so that's a very
important aspect
to be considered that which we need to
uh discuss when we talk about the build
profile so build profile
whenever you feel that you want to do
some customizations and you want to
proceed with the
setup so that's where it's utilized next
thing is that what are different type of
build profiles which is available
there so the build profiles can be done
on for a particular project like per
project you can do
you can uh even do the build profiles in
the settings.xml file also
and if you feel that you want to do it
into the globalsettings.xml file so that
also
you can do as such over here so there
are different ways
in which you can do the customization
and once the customization is done
you will be able to have the different
ways of doing the setups
and the configurations over there so
what exactly is meant
by the uh particular system dependencies
here so
let's talk about that also so system
dependencies refers
to the uh particular mechanisms where we
feel that
how the dependencies should be you know
present there so that is something which
is having a scope of system there
so these dependencies are commonly used
to help me one know the dependencies
that is being provided by the jdk
system dependencies are mostly used to
resolve
the dependencies on the artifacts that
are provided by the
jdk so these dependencies are somewhat
which is being utilized
and used over here so that we will be
able to implement
and go ahead through the system
dependencies what is the reason for
using
an optional dependency here so optional
dependencies are used to decrease the
transitive burden of some libraries so
what happens that
when you download an artifact when you
put up a dependency so it could be a
possibility that
some dependencies as in particular
optional can also be downloaded
now these are not always required but
yes sometimes what happens that these
are downloaded so that you don't have to
put
each and every uh artifact or dependency
into the powder xml file for example
you're trying to download some apache
tool and with that some like three four
jar files or three four another
dependencies are also getting downloaded
now if you are using that dependencies
that totally create because you don't
have to put that uh
list or that entry in the dependency
list in the powder xml file
and that can really save your time but
if you feel that you don't want to have
them
and you these are the optional ones and
you really want to
get rid of that so that also you can
exclude while downloading any kind of
dependencies so these are the optional
ones
which depending on your requirement you
can utilize you can
process and if you feel that you don't
want to get it you won't want to process
it
you can certainly ignore it and you can
get rid of that also
now what is a dependency scope and how
many type of dependencies scope are
there so there are different type of
dependency scores which is there
which is used on each and every stage of
the build here
so compile provided runtime test
system import these are the different
kind of dependency scopes
which we have using which we can define
that when exactly we want to go ahead
for a specific build process so
depending on your requirement
you can explore all these build scopes
and you can get benefits out of that
what is exactly an intransitive
dependency in maven so maven avoids the
need
to find out and specify libraries that
our own dependencies require by
including the transitive dependencies
automatically
so transitive dependency says that if he
depends if x depends on y
and y depends on z then x depends on y
and both there
so which means that you are not
dependent on one artifact
you also need the z artifact there with
the y
artifact so that is what you need to do
so that you will get both the
dependencies there
because this is normal that if you are
trying to
download some particular artifacts or
download some dependency
and that dependency is also dependent on
some other artifact or
some other jar file then you have to
include both of them
so this is something which you will be
able to get so that
you uh can easily download all these
dependent
jar files also and the maven build can
be successful
how can a maven build profile can be
activated so even
build profile can be activated through a
different ways so
explicitly using the command command
line you can
talk about that which profile you want
to execute through maven settings you
can do
uh based on environment parameters os
settings
and present and missing files so these
are the different ways
in which you can actually activate that
which particular profile you want to
have so profiles configurations are can
also be saved in
various situations and various files and
from there you will be able to refer
that which file you want to refer as
such
now what is meant by the dependency
exclusion the exclusion is used to
exclude any transitive dependency
because you never know
that if you are trying to put up a
dependency uh
entry in the power xml file that
artifact is also further dependent on
another artifact so in order to feel in
order to see that you want to exclude
that
dependent artifact which is being
automatically downloaded
that also we can exclude with the help
of exclusion so you can
uh avoid the transitive dependency with
the help of
dependency exclusions here so what
exactly is in mojo so mojo is nothing
but maven plain old java object here
so it's an executable goal in maven and
a plug-in refer to the distribution of
such mozos
so moses enable the maven to extend its
functionality
that already is not founded in so it's
kind of an extension which is there and
using this we can get
some additional benefits and some
executions over there
so what is the command to create a new
project based on a hard drive
so again archetype is something which we
normally use to create uh the new
projects
now you can give the parameters in the
command itself or you want
it to in in kind of an interactive mode
where it will take the parameters from
the end user
and according to that the project will
be created onto hard drive or onto
server wherever you wish
you want to create you can create a new
project
so explain about the maven settings.xml
file so maven settings.xml file contains
the elements that are used to define
that how
the movement execution should be there
so there are different uh settings like
local remote central all these different
repositories are configured as such over
here
now in this case what happens that
usually the configurations are done in
such a way
that it can you know go for the
executions it can go for the build
process
and the complete executions can be uh
involved and can be achieved as such
here so all these
executions are something which we can
really perform and uh
here we can put some credentials how to
connect to the remote repository how to
connect to remote repository
all that stuff is something which we
talked about over here what exactly is
that meant by term
superb form here so superform refers to
the default bomb of
maven so the moms of maven can't derive
from
so it's nothing but a reference to a
parent bomb which is available there
that is a super pump
so if you define some dependencies in
that super pump
automatically the uh child bomb will
also be able to inherit all those
dependencies
so we can put some uh executions like we
can put some
configuration in the super pump so that
if multiple
uh projects are going to refer that they
should be able to refer that easily so
that's the reason why we primarily use
the super pump
so that we can have the execution some
processes
put up over there and all the other
projects should be effort to refer or
inherit from there
so where exactly the dependencies are
stored so dependencies are stored
like in different locations like you
have the local repository
remote repositories there local
repositories on the
local developers machine and remote
repository something which is available
on a server in form of artifactory
and so with this we have come to the end
of this video
i hope you guys find it informative and
helpful
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here